hello everyone and welcome to a really
uh fun game uh from the leachest arena
that was played yesterday and it's a
game between magnus carlson world
champion and the daniel naroditsky and
the two of them have played many games
in
a bullet time format and we all mostly
show uh the the the most interesting
ones on the channel uh but this one it's
uh very short it's like 10 moves and
it's super funny but it does give you an
idea that chess principles are super
important regardless of the time format
so it doesn't matter if it's a two two
hour game or a five minute blitz or or a
one minute bullet as um uh
it was a case in this game so magnus won
the event uh narudisky came in second
and penguin won third place so you guys
wanted me to show now one of the games
this is the one i thought was very funny
uh so let's check it out so magnus has
the white pieces and he opens with d4 we
have knight f6 uh knight to f3 and now
g6 uh the uh the the east indian defense
as it's called knight to c3 and now d5
uh we have bishop to f4 uh fighting for
that uh e5 square and very nicely
controlling it bishop to g7 and now e3
and here we have c5 of course black
strikes in the center as you usually do
and bishop to b5 with check and now
there are some games where bishop to d7
was played but here uh daniel blocks
with knight to c6 and it is now already
as of move six that we have a completely
new game so magnus uh tries to put
pressure on the c6 square he plays
knight e5 attacks the c6 knight here and
the queen to b6 defending the knight and
magnus pushes the a4 pawn so now there
are some tactics involved with pushing
of the pawn at the a5 but black solves
all of his problems by just castling so
now
the knight is no longer pinned and you
don't have all that many problems but
interestingly you can push a5 here just
uh you know for future references if you
guys need it the the thing is if knight
captures an a5 you can play d captures
on c5 and the queen can't capture
because the knight hangs so you have to
go somewhere along this diagonal and now
the game continues with white having um
a very very solid development uh but
okay in the game magnus just castled uh
we have c captures on d4 and now magnus
doesn't recapture instead he plays a5
now and here he's giving black an option
do you want to capture the pawn with
knight captures an a5 then we go into
some queen captures on b4 lines uh or do
you want to just uh move the queen back
queen to d8 but
it seems uh nardiski wanted to keep his
queen very active he played queen to c5
and it seems like the queen is doing
very well there uh you know if black
plays if white plays something weird
then you can easily just continue uh but
there is a problem of course so i'm sure
you guys see it but just in case you
don't feel free to pause the video and
win the game for white while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on realizing that
these three squares are not available to
the black queen and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show of course
it's a move with the knight back and
knight to d3 just wins the game now
these two squares are covered by the
knight and the d6 square is covered by
the bishop this square is covered by the
pawn and this square is covered by the
bishop so the black queen is trapped and
there's nothing to do here uh daniel
played knight cap queen captures knight
on c3 uh before he resigned the game uh
just
for good measure uh probably
uh so yeah uh that's uh it that's one of
the games from the leeches bullet arena
that uh that magnus won the title one uh
and uh he he wins a lot of them not all
of them i remember there was
that one really big way where they were
awarding uh the winner with one thousand
dollars and then he kept giving it back
giving it back giving it back and then
he like won some eight in a row uh and
then he couldn't join on the ninth or
maybe some eight or i don't know and
then uh someone else just won and uh you
know uh to took the money but it was uh
uh very enjoyable just you know trying
to
give back so much and increase the price
fund uh
well hopefully indefinitely but he
didn't get to play one of them uh but
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it a nice short one to take a
break from all the long games that we've
been having but now we are returning to
the long and heavy games and like i said
in the previous video do join our
pre-christmas uh arena the link is in
the description below there will be many
strong players i imagine so you'll have
a chance to face off uh at least some of
them uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it if you have a favorite of
your own do be sure to use hashtag
suggestion or send me an email or
contact me via any social media i would
like to thank francis
weaver sky music emmanuel fretzel duncan
uh weinkel and william fuller for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon uh continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions such as this
one and whatever else is happening in
the chess world uh thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day